Senate Republicans delayed plans to vote
on their health care bill this week at
least 12 GOP senators are concerned
about the legislation Senator Rand Paul
Kentucky says the bill does not go far
enough to repeal the Affordable Care Act
he met with President Trump yesterday to
discuss it he tweeted the president is
quote open to making the bill better his
Senate leadership Senator Paul is with
us now from Capitol Hill senator good
morning good morning
so when you say is Senate leadership
you're talking about Mitch McConnell I
assume what does Mitch McConnell have to
do to make a bill that you don't think
as you have said is Obama light well I
think they've done a lot to placate
moderates they've done a lot to placate
those who want to keep parts of
Obamacare they have kept most of the
Obamacare subsidies they actually keep
the Medicare Medicaid expansion forever
eventually the states have to pay the
traditional historical rate for it but
they've actually kept the Medicaid
expansion of Obamacare we've kept ten of
the twelve regulations so for those of
us who said well we promise to repeal
the whole thing and for those of us who
believe that the regulations are part of
the reason why the premiums are rising
so fast for so many people we think you
have to repeal the regulations if you
want to bring down prices for people so
when you talk to President Trump did he
seem to understand that you know I think
he's sympathetic to the argument and I
think he wants to get it the bill
through and he thinks it's important for
for all of us and for the country that
we repeal Obamacare but I guess I tried
to make sure that he understood that
many of us don't think the current bill
is repealed and so you know we voted 60
times to repeal it all of it or as much
as we thought we could repeal but we
repealed quite a bit of it 60 times and
here we are now actually keeping quite a
bit of it I mean there are those who are
arguing senator as you well know from
being there that what you're trying to
do is achieve tax reform with in health
care and you eliminate the tax reform
and and do that somewhere else in tax
reform legislation you could agree on
health care well I would say that if you
get rid of the taxes but keep the
spending that's not very honest in fact
that was a little bit of the dishonesty
of the whole approach from the beginning
but right now you're right we do get
primarily get rid of the taxes but we
keep the Medicaid expansion but where we
don't have a real
debate is we have still people squawking
that we're not keeping enough Medicaid
expansion when in fact we keep the
Medicaid expansion for seven years we
let people we let the expansion states
continue to expand and it never has been
really an honest accounting with
Medicaid our government if you look at
our budget we're five hundred billion
dollars in the hole we spend five
hundred billion more than comes in now
they play games with the base line so
this is saving money nobody believes
this is saving money they're creating a
brand new insurance pail out fund of a
hundred and thirty billion dollars
there's no way that is paid for with
savings I think it's funny
Washington math senator we heard Mitch
McConnell suggest recently that it might
get to the point of gasp sitting down
with Democrats if the Republicans can't
get on the same page do you see that
happening actually I think once we can
repeal the things that Democrats would
never reveal we should sit down with
Democrats Democrats are never gonna
reveal any taxes or any regulations on
anything and frankly that's what
separates us as parties but once we
repeal the taxes regulations and try to
repeal as much as we can it's still not
going to be completely fixed we should
sit down with Democrats and many of the
ideas that I've had for buying groups
allowing people to associate together
collectively to bring down prices I
think some of those I've talked to many
Democrats who were open to that idea
in Ohio for example the governor came to
rally to get in and raise the case about
Medicaid expansion with his own Senator
Rob Portman isn't Kentucky one of the
largest recipients of Medicaid expansion
they are and what I've said all along is
if in Kentucky we want to keep the
Medicaid expansion we should just be
honest we could pay for it if we doubled
the state income tax and doubled the
sales tax but then what we would do is
we'd be honest legislators and we'd be
saying you know what there are some
trade-offs if we double our income tax
to 12% Tennessee has zero maybe we're
going to lose some business instead what
all people in government do and this is
Republicans and Democrats they punk the
question they say oh the states can't
afford it so we're to send it to the
federal government they have a printing
press but that's not really honest we're
20 trillion dollars in the hole we can't
you know we can't sustain the
entitlements before Medicaid expansion
so we should be honest and we should do
this a
to raise taxes if you want to provide
all this extra health care you gave an
interesting analogy last night on TV
comparing it to kidney stones and
sometimes you got it just pass it no
I've never had those knock on wood but I
hear they're quite painful did you think
that it would be this painful for you
too did you think those process would be
this painful well I have to give credit
to my friend representative Thomas Massa
who came up with the analogy but I do
think it's pretty pretty accurate you
know pass it pass it pass it you can be
done with it but that shouldn't be the
way we look at health care it should be
very much a studied issue and actually
the more we study it as someone said the
more complicated it appears but that's
the other problem with this and I I did
tell anybody who listen you shouldn't
over promise that you can fix health
care health care was broken before
Obamacare that's the very popular face
hidden it it was broken and that was
broken before Obamacare I don't think
Obamacare fixed it but it's still going
to be broken after this Republican bill
mainly because there's not a marketplace
the consumer doesn't make decisions
based on price until you connect the
consumer to the price until you have
real competition and capitalism the
marketplace will still be broken but
isn't that the political problem you
promised for seven years you would
either replace or reform Obamacare and
you can't do it because of divisions
within the Republican Party and now
you've got to go to the voters in 2018
perhaps not having either reformed or
replaced yeah I think you can make two
sections of the Republican Party and the
independents unhappy ones who said you
promised to repeal it and you really
didn't and then also people who just
want the premiums to go down and you
promise make these big promises for
premiums to go down and I fully expect I
think there's a 99.9% chance premiums
don't go down I mean a success would be
that they go up less slowly and so
people have to realize they've gone up a
hundred and five percent in the last six
years but they were rising before
Obamacare also to be fit to be fair
health care has been broken a long time
all right Senator Paul we thank you for
taking the time this morning thank you
we appreciate it